this year we've lost actors who flitted
between movies and television over the
course of their careers while some made
their biggest impact on Broadway what
they all have in common is a dedication
to their craft and a fan pace that will
miss them dearly you might remember him
as Murray Futterman from the 80s classic
gremlins but the man behind the paranoid
World War two vets was prolific screen
actor Dick Miller the Bronx born actor
made quite the name for himself in the
boxing ring while serving in the US Navy
but his career path swerved when he met
legendary b-movie producer Roger Corman
in the 1950s he starred in a number of
Corman's movies but Miller's biggest
role came towards the end of the decade
when he starred as murderous busboy
Walter Paisley in 1959 s a bucket of
blood after variety announced Miller's
death in January Joe Dante who directed
Miller and gremlins among other films
tweeted a tribute to Miller the director
wrote I always looked for a role for
dick not just because he was my friend
but because I loved watching him act but
he leaves behind over 100 performances a
bio and a doc not bad for a guy who
hardly ever enjoyed a starring role
Steven Levy known professionally as
Steve bean sadly succumbed to a rare
form of nose cancer in January 2019 the
comedian and actor went into great
detail about his shock 2016 diagnosis
and an essay titled my year without a
nose published by Mel magazine in 2018
revealing that he'd been given a year to
live after undergoing surgery to remove
his nose my sense of humor came back
about a month ago not a moment too soon
either the latest scans show yet another
recurrence of the cancer the doctors
tell me I have 9 to 12 months to live
Levy managed to fight on for a while
passing away towards the end of January
he was 58
according to Variety the Massachusetts
native got his start on the stand-up
scene becoming a household name in
Boston he later moved to Los Angeles and
started writing for the Tim Conway show
and ABC's dot comedy which gave him a
foot in the door
he scored minor parts and shows like
quantum leap and Murder She Wrote
carving out a career as a dependable
television actor he worked right up
until his diagnosis Levy is survived by
his wife Caroline Kerrigan and his son
Jacob Randall
sci-fi fans will no doubt recognize him
as guest star turned regular Jacob
Carter from Stargate sg-1 but karma no
Jen's Ianno played a variety of roles
throughout a long career in the business
he got his starts in the early 70s and
eventually settled into a career as a
character actor in the decades that
followed becoming a regular on our TV
screens our Jen's Ian OHS agency event
horizon talent announced his passing at
the age of 75 on Facebook where they
called the veteran actor a consummate
gentleman the post made special mention
of our Gen Z on OHS work on Stargate
sg-1 saying the actor had relished being
on the show for seven years many will
remember him as overly optimistic
stuntman Super Dave Osborne but by the
time of his passing writer and actor Bob
Einstein had become known for his role
as Marty funkhauser on HBO's Curb Your
Enthusiasm my nephew who was an all-star
pitcher he's up there now in a cast why
did you have to fight him for the pickle
Einstein passed away in January at the
age of 76
not long after being diagnosed with
cancer shortly after the news broke Curb
Your Enthusiasm star and co-creator
Larry David released a statement saying
never have I seen an actor enjoy a role
the way Bob did playing Marty funkhauser
on curve it was an amazing unforgettable
experience knowing and working with him
there was no one like him as he told us
again and again were all in a state of
shock
Einstein emerged as one of the funniest
writers in Tinseltown during the early
1970s he won his first Emmy for his
early work on The Smothers Brothers
Comedy Hour and picked up his second win
for dick Van Dyke's mid-seventies
vehicle van Dyken company he didn't have
a whole bunch of feature-length
appearances to his name his most notable
film role came in 2007 when he popped up
as agent Caldwell in Ocean's thirteen
when Einstein's pin-point comic timing
and unique gravelly voice made him a
regular on American television
countless actors have played the role of
Ebenezer Scrooge but the Albert Finney
led Scrooge a 1970 version of a
Christmas carol became one of the most
endearing and is still beamed into
households across the UK every December
younger film fans will probably
recognize him from Erin Brockovich and
the James Bond film Skyfall by the time
he appeared in the critically acclaimed
spy
Finney had already fought kidney cancer
in one he was diagnosed in 2007 but was
given the all clear following some
intensive chemotherapy while he was a
popular actor and a critical Darlene
Finney shunned the limelight he turned
down a knighthood from the Queen and
received five Oscar nominations four of
which were for Best Actor but never
showed up to the ceremony once speaking
to the Manchester Evening News in 2012
then he said simply it seems silly to go
over there and beg for an award
Skyfall released in 2012 proved to be
Benny's final film role but the actor
remained with us until February when he
passed away at the age of 82 after what
his family called a short illness it
seems as though Carol Channing was going
to go on forever but the smiley star of
enduring Broadway musical Hello Dolly
sadly died in January 2019 she was 97
years old the Seattle born actress won a
Tony for her career defining portrayal
of Matchmaker Dolly Levi in the
long-running production which paid
tribute to her after learning of her
death the current Hello Dolly touring
company said in a statement we are
deeply saddened by the passing of the
one and only Carol Channing she was a
dolly for the ages and a true icon of
the American theatre she lost out to
Marilyn Monroe when Hollywood adapted
her first theatrical hits Gentlemen
Prefer Blondes for the big screen in the
50s but that didn't stop channing from
trying to crack the whole moving picture
thing the following decade she succeeded
the actress won a Golden Globe and was
nominated for an Academy Award after a
memorable performance in 1967 s
Thoroughly Modern Millie Julie Adams was
one of universals leading ladies during
the 1950's starring in the classic 1954
monster pitcher Creature from the Black
Lagoon
according to THR the studio once
declared her leg's quote the most
perfectly symmetrical in the world and
even insured them to the tune of a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
a staggering amount for the day in
February 2009 teen her son TV editor
Mitchell Danton informed the Hollywood
trade that Adams had passed away in Los
Angeles she was 92 Adams was way more
than just the object of a lagoon
creatures affections she starred
opposite legends Elvis Presley and John
Wayne and made several for raise into
television over the
of a long career and when we say long we
mean long she made her first appearance
in 1949 and her last in a short titled
the lucky southern star in 2018
Guillermo del Toro whose oscar-winning
film the shape of water was something of
a spiritual successor to Creature from
the Black Lagoon was among the famous
mourners I mourn Julie Adams passing it
hurts in a place deep in me we're
monsters swim
she was probably best known for her
engagement to office space star Ron
Livingston at one stage the pair having
met on the sets of 2000 spiit but Lisa
Sheridan managed to hold her own in the
industry after they split in 2003 she
made appearances in CSI Miami and
without a trace the following year and
in 2005 joined the cast of invasion
starring in the ABC mystery series for
two seasons she would go on to land
various supporting parts in a number of
TV shows but invasion turned out to be
an early peak in a career cut short in
February 2009 teen Sheridan's manager
Mitch Klem confirmed to people that the
actress had passed away at the age of 44
we all loved Lisa very much and are
devastated by the loss we all feel she
passed away Monday morning at home in
her apartment in New Orleans sitcom
veteran Katherine Helmond died in
February 2009 teen of complications from
Alzheimer's disease she was 89 years old
her talent agency confirmed that Hellman
whose film career started in the
mid-1950s with biblical epic line of
mourning passed away at home in Los
Angeles said former who's the boss
co-star Judith Light she taught me so
much about life and inspired me
indelibly by watching her work
Katherine was a gift to our business and
to the world and will be deeply missed
many will remember helmand from soap a
controversial parody of the conventional
soap opera she starred as naive
socialite Jessica Tate from 1977 until
1981 when the ABC show stopped airing
helman reunited with ABC in 1984 when
she agreed to play Mona Robinson in
who's the boss the role that she would
ultimately become best known for the
two-time Golden Globe winner was on
who's the boss for eight years appearing
in almost 200 episodes in that time
helman remained a sitcom star warts in
the years that followed popping up and
Everybody Loves Raymond sporadically for
the better part of a decade but she was
more than a TV star she was a regular
Terry Gilliam collaborator appearing in
three of the Monty Python Betts movies
she portrayed mrs. ogre in the cult
classic Time Bandits the surgery loving
mother in Brazil and she even had a role
in drug-fueled tour-de-force Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas playing the hotel
clerk Jan Michael Vincent who is best
known for 80s TV series Airwolf passed
away in February 2009 teen the Denver
native portrayed cello playing
helicopter pilot Stringfellow Hawke on
the show a slight diversion from the
tough guys and rebels he was used to
playing away from the camera Vincent's
had his troubles with the law he pled
guilty to drunk driving in 1997 after
breaking his own neck and a collision
though he avoided jail he wasn't so
lucky in 2000 when he was sentenced to
60 days behind bars for assaulting his
girlfriend the actor reportedly
struggled with alcoholism man clearly
had some demons but Vincent still had
friends in Hollywood when he passed away
in a tweet Vincent's big Wednesday
co-star Gary Busey remembered his old
friend god bless you Jan Michael Vincent
in the spiritual realm he became a teen
heartthrob playing Dylan McKay on decade
defining 90s drama Beverly Hills 90210
and he experienced the recent resurgence
on the CW's Riverdale but the continuing
career of Luke Perry was sadly cut short
in March 2019
the actor was rushed to the hospital
after suffering what his rep described
as a massive stroke at his California
home he remained under observation for a
further five days before passing away
with his family by his bedside he was 52
years old
Perry's Riverdale colleagues took the
news hard but star Cole Sprouse was
determined to remember the good times he
explained to James Corden in March 2019
Luke was one of those guys I I think
that would much rather have us laughing
and telling stories about his life than
sort of lamenting it but yeah he was a
good man if you're a horror fan chances
are you'll recognize character actor
Joseph pilato who passed away in March
2019 at the age of 70 pilato starred in
a number of genre films in the early
stages of his career
which began in 1978 when zombie movie
master George a Romero gave him a minor
role in Dawn of the Dead he would go on
to work with Romero and 1981's night
writers he played the disgruntled
fairground worker in the bizarre biker
gang caper and again in 1985 s Day of
the Dead which marked pilato's most
famous film appearance the Pittsburgh
actor played mentally unstable
antagonist captain Rhodes in the grisly
sequel turning in a memorable
performance despite being the
character's polar opposite in real life
pilato explained during a 2010 interview
with the horror channel I was pretty
left-of-center politically and was very
influenced by my anti-vietnam more
experienced Rhodes was everything and
typical to my political belief and it's
usually very easy to play an opposite or
villainous character and Rhodes was the
epitome his name will forever be
associated with Romero's cult zombie
franchise but what you probably don't
know about pilato is that he almost
appeared in one of the most influential
movies of the 90s he was cast as a Dean
Martin look-alike in Quentin Tarantino's
classic pulp fiction though
unfortunately for him his scene wound up
getting cut from the final film sadly
this is only a portion of the actors who
passed away in 2019 so far here's a look
at some of the other stars who enhanced
our lives before leaving us to soon Paul
Koslow Kaye Ballard Luisa Moretz
Kristoff st. John
Jed Allen Denise - Barry hey Mitzi Hogue
Bibi Anderson Seymour Cassell Richard
admin Isaac Cappy
[Music]